bonjour jean luc pérat de mercier de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
votre réaction à cette décision de
justice est aussi la réaction de vos
collègues salariés de sanofi
oui bonjour à l'écouté cc à
première vue une plutôt une bonne
nouvelle pour les victimes de ceux de ce
médicament de l'ad-pa king il faut
savoir que jusqu'à aujourd'hui les
victimes de la débâcle dans reconnu et
aient été indemnisés par l'office
national d'élimination des accidents
médicaux et cet office était était
lui-même rémunéré pouvoir indemniser les
leaks
donc c'est une bonne nouvelle pour les
victimes mais aussi pour pour chacun
d'entre nous en tant que citoyens et
contribuables puisque en scène lorsque
sanofi sera reconnu comme
responsable et coupable enfin sanofi
devra payer il ne devra pas se contenter
de laisser les victimes être indemnisé
par d'ennemi public donc c'est une
victoire pour les victimes mais aussi
pour pour chacun d'entre nous
aujourd'hui l'association de victimes de
l'ad-pa qui n'accompagnent environ 7500
famille en justice partout en france
quelle réaction également de ces
familles de victimes dont vous parlez
est ce que vous êtes en lien avec
certaines d'entre elles
au repos pourriez vous cache
effectivement né tallinn avec avec
l'association la pessac
travail
et il faut bien savoir aussi parce que
en tant que syndicaliste j'ai aussi je
porte aussi un intérêt pour les
travailleurs et du midi car il faut
savoir que les travailleurs du
médicament notamment ceux qui
travaillent sur le valproate de trous de
sodium en 2018 et depuis déjà certaines
certainement bien plus de noms plus
longtemps que cela
les salariés du site de moyens je les
fabrique et la dea paquin ont eux mêmes
été exposés à au valproate de soyaux
c'est à dire la dea paquin il faut
savoir que pendant des années l'institut
de mourenx a rejeté jusqu'à 20 tonnes de
despatie dans l'atmosphère donc bien sûr
que l'on suit de près cette affaire
parce que nous aussi en tant
qu'organisations syndicales cgt et par
rapport à ces expositions due à des
pollutions disposition des salariés nous
avons déposé plainte contre x au
tribunal de paris pour mise en danger
d'autrui pour les styles elle n'y a pas
eu de suite à cette plainte mais on
admet bon espoir que ça cette avancée
fasse en sorte que ça accélère aussi
notre notre procédure mais oui on
travaille aussi à la paix
sanofi a d'ores et déjà fait part de son
intention de faire appel du jugement
comme en compte se défendre
le groupe pharmaceutique français à
votre employeur
alors là sur la défense de mon employeur
il faudra leur poser la
question nous ce que ce qu'on peut voir
c'est que il ya quand même derrière
derrière cette cette sordide histoire il
ya quand même des victimes et ses
victimes la somme sous des désastres en
quoi est il est vrai que ça fait déjà
quelques années que cette histoire dure
sanofi
va faire appel donc ça va encore aux
poussées et juge magne savait encore
l'europe où se repousser pour quelques
années et c'est vrai que tintin on se
dit que quand on est capable de verser 4
milliards de dividendes de ses
actionnaires comme on le sait le groupe
sanofi on doit être capable de prendre
la mesure de cette situation vis-à-vis
de la de paquin il doit être capable de
trouver un peu d'argent pour indemniser
les indemniser des victimes des victimes
des paquin voilà après sanofi va
certainement ceux des fans et il en a le
droit et je pense qu'il va le faire il
va essayer de la faire le plus discret
possible
lancé il ya quand même voilà il ya quand
même des choses qui trompait pas et
quand même là msn kia qui a reconnu avec
la crise sécurité sociale la
responsabilité quand même deux de sanofi
sur des malformations sûr sûr sûr les
nantais il y aurait quand même entre
2000 et 4000 enfants concernés et aussi
sur des troubles neurologie que là aussi
sur des internes et là il y aurait entre
16000 et 30000 enfin concernés vous
voyez qu'on est quand même sur sur des
chiffres est assez important et je pense
que voilà sanofi de jouer devait jouer
de sa de ces deux monstres hideux de
responsabilité et de faire de faire
profil bas après ou alors on le sait le
médicament est un principe actif il faut
l'utiliser dans de bonnes conditions
peut-être que sanofi a pas été assez
vigilant sur sur certaines conditions
d'utilisation et pour cela il doit il
doit être il doit être jugé comme
responsable si les responsables mais il
ya aussi l'état qui est responsable de
cette histoire parce que on l'a il ya
des choses qui sont remontés qu'ils ont
été reconnus par ainsi que de social est
derrière rien n'a été fait non plus pour
obliger sanofi à être être mis face à
ses responsabilités
entre le scandale de la dea patiner le
nouveau report 1
d'un vaccin anti commis de sanofi
quelles conséquences pour le groupe
pharmaceutique est ce qu'il peut y avoir
une perte de confiance du public dans ce
laboratoire donc potentiellement moins
de commandes et peut-être des pertes
d'emploi pour vous et vos collègues
salariés de sanofi est ce que vous
pensez à ça parce que ce que vous avez
peur
alors pour environ 1 juste une
'correction' sanofi repas va pas mettre
à disposition des passages des patients
l'accès mais simplement
d'aider dose de rappel on s'est un peu
différente le coup effectivement ce sera
un accès mais seulement un accès de
rappel
ceci étant précisé ai dit
vous savez ça mon fils n'a pas tenu de
le scandale de la dea paquin pour pour
supprimer des postes et c'est peut-être
parce que ça fait déjà parce que ça fait
déjà plus de 10 ans que sa minutie
supprime des postes
c'est peut-être pour ça qu'on est
aujourd'hui dans l'incapacité de de
sortir un accès au camp nou comme nos
concurrents ont pu le faire contre la co
lead est aussi incapable d'être à
disposition des patients ont contre la
corrida il faut qu'un de savoir qu'un
design est effectif on recherche et
développement en france ont diminué de
quasiment 50% ben voila vous fait pas
d'omelette sans casser des oeufs et
aujourd'hui ben je pense qu on en est à
un point où on n'a qu'à signer ce qui va
avec et c'est d'autant plus dommageable
que
voilà c'est sanofi t'es qu'un nouvel
laboratoires pharmaceutiques et on voit
bien que petit à petit mais ça nous qui
est en pleine de perdre son âme et
armures et c c'est dommage c'était quand
même et ça l'est toujours mais je parle
au passé mais ça ici et quand même le
fleuron de l'industrie pharmaceutique et
c'est aussi sur sanofi que monsieur
maternité pour la relocalisation de la
fabrication de certains principes actifs
de certaines médicaments donc là aussi
fait poser des questions vous savez que
le président de la république
mais entre les mets mes voisins et même
des entreprises auprès d'apple a aussi
pour porter à questionnement merci jean
luc perrein d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
coordonnateur cgt sanofi